this episode is brought to you by
headspace life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a one
and done
band-aid quick is fine but we need stuff
that is durable and that's where
headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10
minutes headspace can change your life
headspace
offers a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute
sos meditation for you need some help
falling asleep headspace has wind down
sessions their members swear by and for
parents headspace even has morning
meditations you can do with your kids
headspaces approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy i think
it's puddicum could be putty comb i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic
voice imaginable and i did a three
minute meditation something like that
it's easy it's fundamental and it always
puts me in a better
space so i'm going through the basics
even though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today
this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks when you're running your own
business
it's easy to get weighed down by work
that doesn't get you paid that's why i
love freshbooks and have been
recommending
them for years on this podcast it's an
all-in-one accounting and invoicing
solution built
for small business owners like you i've
polled tons and tons of my listeners and
readers
who have brought up fresh books over and
over again and you guys have better
things to do so do i then get caught up
in admin work
whether you're a podcaster or a creative
agency you can choose a plan that's
right for you
freshbooks has been used by more than 24
million people
and it can save you more than 11 hours a
week by automating invoices
expense tracking online payments and so
much more
easy to understand reports an intuitive
dashboard let you know at a glance where
your business stands
you can create customize and send
branded and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds
you can also avoid that awkward exchange
with your clients about overdue payments
freshbooks automates sending late
payment email reminders
and allows you to send a customized
message on your behalf
freshbooks is a simple and intuitive
tool for small business owners but if
you ever need a bit
of help wrapping your head around
something they have an award-winning
toronto-based support team who are
always
happy to help so try freshbooks free for
30 days no credit card required go to
freshbooks.com
tim and enter tim ferriss in the how did
you hear about us section
that's freshbooks.com tim and enter my
name
tim ferriss 2rs2s in the how did you
hear about a section one more time
that is freshbooks.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class performers from all
different disciplines all different
areas
and also to have people on who curate
best
practices and i consider my guest today
to be
someone who falls into both of those
camps his name is greg
mckeown at gregory mcewen spelled
m-c-k-e-o-w-n
naturally he is the author of the new
book effortless
subtitle make it easier to do what
matters most and a previous book
of which i am a huge fan essentialism
subtitle the discipline pursuit
of less which hit the new york times
bestseller list and has sold more than a
million copies
and i have saved my highlights from that
book
in my kindle in evernote printed them
out highlighted them
read them dozens of times that is how
highly i
think of this particular work he is also
a speaker and the host of the popular
podcast
what's essential he has been covered by
the new york times the new yorker fast
company fortune politico
inc and many other outlets and is among
the most popular bloggers on linkedin he
is also a young global leader for the
world economic forum originally from
london
england he now resides in california
with his wife and their four children
you can find him online
at greg mcewen.com m-c-k-e-o-w-n
once again on twitter at gregory mcewen
facebook greg mcewen speaker instagram
gregory mckeon
greg welcome back to the show tim it's
great to be back with you
and i thought we would start with some
leftover bits from our first episode and
for people
who are interested in knowing how much
content will be
overlapping or redundant my goal is to
make it close to zero
so in other words if you want the joyful
experience of listening
to conversations with greg we had a
blast in our first conversation and
my goal is to dig in areas we didn't
have a chance to explore last time and
i'm going to start with one that might
seem very random
and it's more of a fragment than
anything else because i don't have much
context and that is
what is gandhi's only poem and how did
you come across it
well gandhi became a barrister in
london and might have stayed a barrister
but he had an emergency come up in
south africa with his family there so he
travels to south africa
and while he's on the train he's kicked
off
he is told you can't be in first class
and he won't leave
uh he's bought the tickets he's allowed
to be there from his point of view but
it's in the middle of apartheid
and he is not permitted to be there as
an indian so they throw him off and that
becomes a decisive moment for him
what am i going to do and it was
essential enough that he decides to stay
and
fight the law that allowed them to
physically throw him off the train
and he was successful but it took him a
long time he was there for 23 years
before he was successful had to go to
jail along the way a whole series of
things
after that he went to india and what
he's best known for
uh the great uh standoff with the
british empire and he
he wins through a series of essentialist
experiments really
he figures out what is essential the
thing that's going to matter and what
he finds is salt that infinitesimally
small
but infinitely important item salt was
one of the reasons the british could so
effortlessly
control so many indians and so
yeah they controlled the production of
salt and therefore of bread and the
whole
food chain and so that was where the
idea came to him to be able to
walk across india in the demonstration
of civil disobedience and make salt
at the beach became known as the salt
march because some
six hundred thousand indians followed
him and the british stand back and said
well look who is this man
and where does his power come from he's
got no political position
he's got no money and yet he's able to
command this sort of loyalty this type
of leadership and
that continues until eventually he
brings independence to the largest
democracy in the world
at that time 300 million people of
course now
far beyond a billion as became the
father of
india uh when he died the u.s secretary
of state
said here is a man who has shown that
simplicity is more powerful than empires
and einstein said of him generations to
come will scarce believe that such a one
is this
ever in flesh and blood walked upon this
earth i mean this is all
high praise and i i think deservedly
when i happen to have the opportunity to
speak about essentialism in south africa
i went to the phoenix settlement where
he lived for that 23 years to the house
where he lived
i was given what i was told was the only
poem
he ever wrote and i found in there
four words that to me
a great mantra for life and also
really the the very essence of
essentialism and
they were this reducing oneself to zero
and that really is what gandhi was all
about what he was doing was stripping
himself
of all the things that maybe other
people thought they needed to do the
other politicians at that time or just
everyone else who's
accumulating stuff or wealth or
all these things and he just said but i
just want to pursue
my essential mission what it was i came
here to do and it's about that stripping
away process and so to me those words
are beautiful words they're powerful
words
they've come to be a symbol a mantra
an ideal that i want to work towards
thank you for all the context i i was
familiar
with the use of salt as a symbol
by gandhi and
i was so impressed by
how he was able to
and really in in many respects needed to
but others would have failed
keep his use of symbols
extremely simple he was able to use
simplicity with such great power
and i'm curious if there are
symbols that you use for yourself
and they might take the form of mantras
reducing oneself to zero
are there other symbols for you i know
we spoke of a piece of artwork called
the listener
last time which i looked up and enjoyed
so much that i ended up
buying a print of it to put on my wall
perhaps you could take a moment just to
describe that but are there other
symbols
does anything come to mind when i ask
that question that you use
for yourself maybe not so much for
others yeah speaking first to the
listener
i i mean the the idea behind this is by
james christensen and he
always writes up a description
of his paintings so it's not just
that they sort of speak for themselves
he speaks for them he's passed away now
unfortunately but what he says about the
listener he says look in this
sort of dolby surround sound of our
daily lives we
all have to find the mute button and his
idea is that
that since a painting can't have a
soundtrack that the title character
at the center of the listener you know
has found that the best way to shut off
the noise
in the visual cacophony that's in the
painting is to close his eyes
and so that's really the image it's
someone who's listening
to his still small inner voice and
remaining
centered without being overcome it's to
find
peace in a busy world and that's what
he's capturing and so to me
that i mean on this picture there's
images of
picasso you can find lots of famous
people on there politicians and so on
and i think his mother-in-law's in there
but it's all these people trying to pull
on his attention and his energy and
that listener is at the center and so
that's why it's a favorite painting for
me
because and i have it in my office here
is as a reminder with all that goes on
all the noise all the competing voices
to
to listen not even how we would say to
our own voice so to speak
not just to what i want what i want to
go after in life but
quieter even that a different voice a
friend of mine describes the difference
between
the scared voice and the sacred voice
and i need to get past
you know even the scared voice that
might be mine and get to that stiller
sacred voice inside and and that's
that's why i love it that's why that is
a symbol to me in terms of
other symbols for me uh one that
just came to mind after you ask the
question is actually another painting
oh man i am i am emotional
even um even thinking about this
so i've got to tell a story to
put it into context please is that is
that okay
um more than okay encouraged
so a few years ago anna and i'm
four children we moved into beautiful
area it's white picket fences this is
there's no street lamps it was like it
was built in the 50s and the whole world
moved on and nobody told anyone here and
you've got more horse ways than the
roads
and it was just this beautiful
environment
to raise our children in and one of my
daughters eve
especially thrived she just like
never wears shoes anywhere she's always
climbing trees she's this
voracious reader she writes masses in
her journal every night she
loves to name the chickens the animals
she's she's just
full of light and energy i once i often
take one of my children with me when i
travel and so one of one of the trips
was on with her an hour into the trip i
literally text my wife i'm like she has
not stopped talking
for one hour she's just just just
pouring out of her
and she's just vivacious and amazing and
she just as i say especially seemed to
thrive in this new environment with
space and out in nature
and then she turned 14 and she
taught less she took longer to do her
chores
less sevacious a little more awkward and
anna and i just said well this is pretty
age-appropriate behavior you know that's
that's can happen that's fine but then
in a
routine physical therapy
visit she failed this very
basic test and the physical therapist
just said
dana pulled her aside and said look that
really is unusual that shouldn't have
happened
you might just want to go to a
neurologist about this
and you don't have to be warned twice
right you're like you don't have
oh well i'll get i'll get to that you
know we we immediately
did this and you know it got our
attention and we
we take her to a neurologist and what we
had previously put
up as being just
evidences of being a teenager we
suddenly saw through a new lens and
realized that these behaviors might be
much more
important than they were um and
also as we then paid attention we found
that her
capabilities inexplicably
were just in a freefall
so instead of being vivacious and
outgoing she just
stopped almost speaking at all in
sentences it would be like one word
answers to anything the emotion went out
it was like taking a you know one of
these old record players and you just
make it ghost really slowly i mean she
couldn't even
like she would take her two minutes to
write her
own name uh 45 seconds i remember
timing it to write the last three
letters of mcewen
and and we went to neurologist after
neurologist i mean we're doing the
things that we could do
and that they couldn't even give us
the beginning of a diagnosis everything
came back
negative sort of good news but bad news
because you have no idea what's going on
and she is fully on the way
to becoming comatose and then you know
dying in a coma i mean that is literally
where we are and we don't have
anything to go on
and uh i remember in the midst of this
i mean this is the stuff that agony is
made of right this is already a
three four month period i remember
getting
very quiet and actually i'm frank to say
i mean i
i was praying about just what on earth
to do
and then words came to me
the words of a painting that we have in
our home
the words that came to me clearly was
she will find what is lost
and that is the name of this painting
and it's a beautiful painting
people can look it up it's the image of
a woman
and many other people
that sort of symbolically look a bit
like
angels but you could interpret it a few
different ways but they're all
she can't see them in the painting but
they're all trying to touch her they're
trying to bless her they're trying to
reach her
and there's no further explanation of
that painting but for me
it means of course a very different
thing
in that moment there is an assurance
that no evidence can support
and we don't even at this point have a
diagnosis
never mind a treatment never mind it's
going to be okay
i mean nothing's going to be okay
logically
nothing is okay but somehow there is
this
sense beyond it it's been a long journey
it's been two years of all of this has
happened since you and i
last spoke on here and she's had
treatment
quite miraculously had certain
treatments
in order to test they said we're going
to treat her
in order to learn what might be going on
we had one neurologist who had that
very clever idea about how you might use
treatment instead of wait for a pure
diagnosis and then treat you treat in
order to learn
and learned a great deal then returned
back into
much of the state before and just over
this summer so in the midst of the
pandemic
went through an aggressive treatment end
and is back
i mean she's back and i wouldn't have
said that once in two years
but as of this moment she has found what
is
what was lost she's vivacious and funny
in fact i just put
on instagram yesterday a video of all of
our children dancing we can get to why
they were dancing uh but
uh they they're all dancing in the
kitchen and i just managed to clip just
an image before they realized i was
videoing them you know
that's a symbol to me that matters
and how that answer came
is so connected also to the listener in
this deep
principle yeah that's the answer to your
question
thank you greg i can't even imagine how
terrifying and profoundly difficult
that time must have been
for you and your family are there any
other approaches or tools
that you found supporting words anything
that helped not just you but also the
family
during that period of uncertainty
especially well
one of the other impressions i had was
to look up
a chapter in a book that i had read
before
and it was about cultivating
a spirit of optimism and
happiness i think that's the name of the
chapter
and i didn't just feel like oh i should
just read that again
but i did feel that the sensation was i
should do it every single day
and i did because you know you need
whatever
real help you can get in this moment and
what
seemed to happen in that extremity
was that there were neural
patterns in me that
were being rewired
so on a daily basis every temptation
exists
to fall into very unproductive emotions
and
habits something like this is so out of
your control it's so vital i mean
there's a
there's a variety of things that you
could fall into
but one of the things you can fall into
is just
of course you could be complaining you
could fall into what i would call
the heavy path depression exhausted you
you could try to solve the problem just
through sheer effort you know we could
just
everything is going to be there's not
going to be any space for anyone
but eve you could destroy
your marriage you could destroy your
family culture
all of these things weren't just
hypothetical i mean they were right
there there was that opportunity and as
i was
listening i read first of all and then
started listening every day to
and i hardly missed a day in those first
four months of listening to that
there was this other path this path of
of trusting
of of hope of good things to come
and the necessity to choose that path
and i would now call that
the lighter path i mean it's it doesn't
feel super light
but it's lighter than the first and
so what grew out of that was
instead of the heavier path well
why is this happening to us why us
instead of
going down just all worst case scenarios
is everyone
trying to be helpful of course but
sending well maybe she has this maybe
she has that you know they're not
doctors a neurologist but they're trying
to help but these things they're sending
to you are just like catastrophic
diagnosis you know and instead of that
path
it was like this it was is there
anything
that we can be grateful for oh then
we're gonna say it
say it clearly say it loud say it to
each other if we can see
anyone doing something right we're going
to talk about it in our family
if we could find humor my eldest
daughter grace used to hold eve's hand
as they'd go to
class or if they were going to and she
would just walk with her
and she would just do anything to make
her laugh there was a little
sense of humor still in her it was
definitely different but she didn't move
one iota away from her you know
sometimes people
in awkwardness or whatever want to move
away and she didn't
and so she brought humor into it we
would get around the piano and we would
sing we would
read together at night we would we would
do the small
and simple and even enjoyable things
and so what was at times agonizing
but could have been seriously worse even
was actually punctuated with joy
i mean it actually made us
it made our family culture when this
pandemic happened it was almost like we
had
a cultural antidote or something
that we all knew instinctively how to
be and how to just we're just going to
invest in the culture again that's the
first thing we're going to protect that
asset
so all these things we can't control
don't control what's going on inside of
our family and this culture and it was a
great advantage in fact
in that sense when all of these things
happened around us
i've come to think of that as being
these two paths
heavier path a lighter path that you can
always make something
however rough it is worse by a response
or you can always make something a
little
easier by your response thank you greg
do you recall and maybe i just didn't
hear it but
the name the title of the book you
mentioned you were reading a chapter and
if you don't we can put it in the show
notes later and i can get it from you
after we speak but do you recall offhand
what the title of the book is
the author of the piece it's a
combination of
lots of different talks and speeches and
in writing
is gordon b hinckley i mean he's a
church leader
and i mean one of the truly most dynamic
leaders
i've ever ever met ever known you can go
and see him on
old recording of larry king and so on
when he was still alive he was uh
on 16 minutes all over incredibly
dynamic leader
but just tremendously optimistic it was
able to
to have an impact a positive impact all
over the world uh he wrote a different
book
not the one i was referencing although
there's overlap called standing for
something that did
uh you know did extremely well and yeah
we can get
the item for the show notes okay great
so the author is gordon b
hinckley and we'll get the title and for
those listening we'll put this
in the show notes at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast coming back to a
few things that you said
as a segue so you mentioned in the
throes of this
situation with circumstances
outside of your control there is a very
understandable temptation to
white knuckle and throw
everything including the kitchen sink at
it to
to make it because it is
that is your daughter's health and and
restoring it
become the top priority and i think
there's a very understandable
impulse to basically allow that to
remove all the oxygen from the room
and that you fix it by applying
more work by working harder
by increasing the volume and
i i suppose that's as good a bridge as
any
to effortless to your new book so i i
really
have deliberately not done any homework
on the subject matter aside from a
handful of notes that i have in front of
me
but it's timely for me also because
i feel like it is possible to
use essentialism and 80 20
analysis and so on to determine the most
important things to focus on and even to
following that focus on them but in so
doing
i think there is probably and i'm
stretching a bit here and i'm gonna
hand the mic over there is a heavier
path and there's a lighter path
there's a path of spaciousness that's a
word i've been thinking a lot about
with respect to my own life ease in
spaciousness
does this have to be difficult is a
question that i
ask more and more frequently so could
you tell us
the genesis story of this book or
comments
in any way that you think is appropriate
you just nailed it
and i couldn't have written
this book a few years ago
i mean you know the pressure there is
it's a positive pressure but the
pressure there is if you've written a
book that's been successful to write the
next one and you're
supposed to do it every 18 months or
whatever the normal cycle is and every
time i went to do it i felt like i
shouldn't
but i didn't know why there was no
really good reason i wanted to
i liked it but just felt like no you
just
wait which isn't great for me i'm not
particularly patient person
but i did and i lit just literally
couldn't have written
this book without the experiences
including
definitely including the experience with
eve and and so in fact that is sort of
the background is that
so essentialism comes out i mean that
changes everything for me i'm traveling
all over the world as
you know it's just and it's what i want
to be doing there's no complaint in
any of this i mean i want to be in with
rooms full of people who
want to become essentialists and want to
hear about it i mean
everything in my life is now more want
to do than before
i remember doing a book signing it was
like on
one of these trips i was on is like 300
people around the building and they've
run out of books they've never done that
before and
i go back to the room at night and it's
just like
sort of these things are a blur and one
of the groups i work with
successful entrepreneurs i was working
with them and one of them says
it talks about this the big rock theory
and we will all know the big rock theory
right is uh you've got this container
and if you put in the small
grains of sand first and then the small
rocks and then the big rocks it doesn't
fit right that's the first part and
that's
how it's supposed to work is that if you
put big rocks in first then the small
rocks then the sand then it all fits and
that's like
first of all i mean i believe that
forever and it's very analogous to
essentialism
uh you know invest in the the big rocks
are the essential things your health
and your relationships then your
important projects and and all of that i
feel is
true and right but i started to feel
that there were
cracks in my assumptions because
i was being more selective than i had
ever been i'm not writing the next book
i
pause on the stanford class i was
co-teaching
and the list could go on there's
significant things i'm not doing i've
been trying to be highly selective
but i'm also by this point you know not
father of essentialism whatever the
father of four children now and so
there's all of that and
you want to be there for them and how
they're inconvenient that can feel to be
there and to respond and so
the question that grows up for me as i'm
traveling one day is just like yeah but
what happens if you have too many big
rocks
need a bigger jar no kidding you need it
right like like that's like for
that's for real right and and
and it's like yeah i'm being selected
but what do you do
you're being waterboarded by opportunity
wait yes yes sure and and and we can say
it
less by responsibility sure
that these are things you want to do
they are essential that you like
so now you've got a choice of what to do
you can either
fail you can actually just say well that
doesn't okay i'm not doing that
essential thing
or you've got to come up with something
else and as i'm out there
traveling and i'm having this thought i
get a phone call
and it's my son jack on my wife's
phone which is gets my attention
and and i'm hearing him he's like pale
faced and he's trying to explain
you know eve was eating and this and
that and my wife's saying
turn the phone around and and this is
when she's having her first massive
tonic planet seizure so
i'm already feeling too many rocks and
then you throw in a crisis
that like just blows everything up
adrenaline gets me through the next
few hours right we're taking the red eye
back hospital visits and all the
neurology appointments and everything
i've just been talking about but normal
life doesn't stop
your normal responsibilities don't
suddenly just disappear
and that was really when i remember it
took me probably longer than maybe
it would for other people to just admit
it you know is
right essentialism you don't want to be
admitting this perhaps
but it took me a while and finally i'm
just like anna look i'm just not i'm not
well
and what i learned through that crucible
was i was doing the right things
and that's essentialism but i was doing
it in the wrong way
and effortless is about doing the right
things but in the right way
i was like the weight lifter who's
lifting with their back i
i'm like the you know i don't know a
baker's do it
needing the dough all by hand instead of
by a machine i mean
i'm doing the right things but maybe i'm
doing them in a hard way is
so this is the point of decision that's
like do you put the rock down or do you
find an easier path
if you can't work any harder you've got
to find an easier path and i
think there's a lot of people yes it
might not be
the daughter and the situation
specifically as i'm describing but
if nothing else the pandemic itself
that has pushed people to a similar
point high achievers
high performers who are on the edge of
exhaustion
they can't work any harder and yet their
impulse is to work harder
because that's what got them here that's
what got them success and so
even as they approach exhaustion burnout
or even go past it they still think
well the only way out of this that's
what i've done before it's been hard
work i'll just
hard work my way out of this and i think
that's
a really high risk and it certainly
in hindsight would have been for us if
we had
gone down the harder path the heavier
path
we would have nothing left to deal with
the second time when she relapsed i mean
we would have you're all spent
and then what do you give up then what
do you lose you're losing more and more
rocks all the time so that's really
is the story behind effortless
is this requirement this need to
discover is there an easier path and a
joy for me now when i feel real
responsibility for this
is to bring that to people because i
just i just know i feel quite emotional
about talking about this book
because of what we've covered i suppose
but also because i
somehow can feel it in me the
unbelievable burdens
that people are in right now some of
them talked about
many of them done in silence especially
if you're a high performer you just
i mean this is the problem there's this
group of people and it's an expanding
group of people
these are the people who aren't
complaining so they they're silent
they're just
they're pivoting when you need to pivot
they're working hard they're doing what
it takes they're doing home education
now suddenly
this group has spent a year in this mode
and i think a lot of them are closer to
breaking than they've ever been i mean i
just read 85 percent of people feel
their well-being is
is worse than it was a year ago and
that's just one
symbol of this and so to me
uh in ways i absolutely didn't predict
and couldn't have predicted
i think effortless is an idea
potentially whose time has come because
as we really in a way unfortunately it
hits at a time when i think it
has the power of relevancy
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by you
can ucan what you eat and how you live
exercise sleep stress all play an
important role in how your body handles
glucose
its main form of energy you might think
of blood sugar
that is glucose when glucose levels are
steady and you avoid spikes
you are improving your metabolic fitness
an important way to take control of your
metabolic fitness is to eat and fuel
with foods that help
regulate blood sugar to help enhance my
own metabolic health
i was introduced to you can by dr peter
attia who said there is no carb in the
world
like it ucan's patented ingredient super
starch
has the remarkable ability to provide a
steady release of energy without
spiking blood sugar levels i use ucan's
energy powders and low calorie bars
to maintain focus throughout long days
for exercise
better performance when training and to
avoid fatigue without making
metabolic compromises when i need a
scooby snack when i need a little
pick-me-up
i reach for you can ucan has a variety
of different products with super starch
to help you balance your blood sugar
from energy powders and bars
to granola and almond butter there's a
whole suite check out my favorites at
ucan.co tim that's ucan dot co slash tim
and save 30 on your first order when you
use code
tim that's ucan dot co
slash tim and use code tim you can dot
co
slash tim
so greg where would you suggest we go
from here
and i rarely ask that question in
interviews but we have a lot of options
and you're probably more aware of the
range of those options than i am there
are
notes in front of me that we could
explore because i'd love to
certainly share tactics and specifics
with people
in terms of what you've learned and what
you're applying what seems to be
giving you the best effortless return on
investment so to speak
uh what has sort of changed your
experience of
working on the essentials for instance
so i'll just give a sampling i'm not
saying this is the direction we have to
go but
why you need to done for the day list
solve problems before they exist
visualizing what done looks like
how to take the first obvious action
harnessing the strength of ten
these are just a few that i circled for
myself because i found them curious
first step to clearing the clutter in
your head how effortless inversion can
help solve a problem
how to make your essential activities
enjoyable and on and on and on we have
dozens of options here
or we could take a different fork in the
road
and i'd love to get your thoughts
on what makes sense certainly i want
people to come away from this interview
if they are unable to read your book
with some
approaches strategies tactics or
techniques that they can use
well i didn't come into this with
an answer to that question of course but
i think
i think we need to before just
shifting to tactics i think we need to
at least
have a perspective
a bit broader about how to even think
about this
effortless way and we may find
some interesting ways to explore that
great there's three
in a sense effortless is almost three
books in one
they're connected but the first
is like three concentric circles in the
middle there's
effortless state then second is
effortless action
and third is effortless results and they
build on each other
but they're still quite distinct an
effortless state
is i mean it's it's something we all
know
but we also know being out of the
effortless state
being out of the effort the state is
like you know i mean it definitely
happens
to many people me included end of the
day you're exhausted you you start to
see
everything people say as you get an
email it sounds like a slight to you you
can't find your keys nothing nothing's
working it's and it's because you're
fatigued but
one of the things i found in the
research is that when you're fatigued
you actually don't you're not a good
judge of being fatigued so
so you think you're seeing things as
they are but you're really just seeing
them as you are
and so you start to get everything wrong
everything starts to feel
hard and one of the the enjoyable
to me ideas is really that that even
when things
seem very hard many problems can be
solved by
you know having a warm meal a hot shower
and a good night's sleep
you wake up the next morning and
suddenly you find the keys right where
you left them and you
you know you suddenly you see the email
you received it's like i don't know i
know how to respond to that gracefully
it's no problem
and suddenly things are back in their
proper perspective and that's just one
way of thinking about this effortless
state
and part of the deeper work of
effortless state
is to do with figuring out
what is cluttering you up right now
i think of each of us as having
super computer capabilities i mean our
mind is so advanced it's so
impressive it is built for figuring
things out and
processing and so on and and yet
it's just like my laptop can be
at times starting to run slow because of
all of the
all of the cookies that have been added
to it and so on and
the metaphor is well in a few seconds
you can clear all of that out of
the machine and it's working a lot
faster in a similar way
i think one of the most important effort
of strategies is
to figure out what's burdening us
you know what we're holding on to and so
this is different than a sort of quick
fix approach it's like we have to maybe
do a little
deep searching in terms of what
we're holding on to what grudges we're
holding on to
but we haven't forgiven what complaints
we're holding on to things that are
using up more and more of
our hard drive our ram so that it's
making
everything harder there's a story i came
across of a
of a man who it's a fictional story of
a man who was walking along is respected
in his community
he leans over sees a little piece of
string on the floor he picks it up he
likes to
fix stuff and he just got that could be
useful and then the same day at the same
time in the same square
somebody else loses their wallet they
see him picking this
thing up and they assume and believe
it's the lost wallet
accuse him of it tell everybody about it
he insists it's not true but they they
judge him harshly
and so he's like a pariah in the town
and everybody is
wherever he goes they you know it's
awkward now they don't trust him now
this of course is a rough experience but
he gets so fixated on it so obsessed by
it
that he just can't stop talking about it
everywhere he goes
it's a little piece of string it was
just a piece of string and he just even
after people would have got over it
moved on and okay just kind of forgotten
it no no worries
he's still raising it he's talking about
he gets sick over he loses his health
over it
he literally on his deathbed if it kills
him he's on his deathbed a little piece
of string that was a little piece of
string you know he just can't do it and
so
here he is he could have got back to
what was essential what
mattered he could have got back to
making a contribution put all of his
energy
onto what really was important but
instead
he's consumed with
this like that he's experienced this
judgment this harsh judgment and so on
and
i don't know why i'm really thinking
this right now but
i just wonder for you
um here
here we go finally let's take the gloves
off and get dirty
i mean for you are there
burdens grudges things that you haven't
forgiven
things that you've collected that you
are holding that are just
making life harder than they need
to be in some way and i really don't
know if you
have something here i just feel in this
moment and
i'm just putting it to you what is your
first thought when i ask you that
with respect to does it uh would you
like me to speak to grudges specifically
or other types of
let's just call it withhold or
kind of persistent psychic
drag things that fit in that category
it's a good description what you just
had i mean i'm open to both but
i'm just gonna put grudges to you
all right so i will say that
a lot has happened since you and i
last spoke and i took our conversation
very seriously and i i i
won't spend a lot of time revisiting it
but we went through
an exercise about with respect to
finding the essential
and identifying the blocks the obstacles
both real and more often perceived
the reasons for not doing the essential
the commitments i'd made to the
inessential
etc and a lot has happened since then
that might and just to be precise on
that what you were talking about at that
time was
the thing you identified was a book that
you wanted to
write that you were writing in fact you
spent years working on it
but there was the drag was just feeling
somehow
so burdened with this has to be perfect
and i feel like i might get judged quite
harshly if i
if i do this and and how i intend to do
it and so there were things that were
keeping you from
actually proceeding with it and
it felt to me i don't need to overstate
it but a moment of
at least small breakthrough that's how i
remember it
it was very insightful and it stuck with
me
and i had a lot of conversations with
people i trust afterwards
and many months later decided
to take the easier path and what i mean
by that is
i had in my mind the
assumption or the belief that it should
be a book
and the most important component of that
entire book on healing
was the disclosure of childhood
abuse childhood sexual abuse in my case
from age two to four
and the tools and approaches that had
most helped me
to heal from that that was really the
that is the
core of the book that i had intended to
write
there's a lot more to it there's a lot
more surrounding it there are many
concentric circles as you might say but
that was really the
the key piece and i don't want to
interrupt you but i want to
say clearly thank you to you now i've
i've shared that
outside of this moment but it's so
important
what you have done in sharing this
and putting it out there and
that takes courage as we all know
courage is awful
feels awful and you've done it and
it really matters thank you for saying
that and
to try to tie this together i ended up
releasing it as a podcast after
conversations with my girlfriend
and understanding that books take a long
time especially my books because the
size of phone books and
in three to five years people would die
whether of natural causes or suicide or
otherwise or they might
psycho emotionally shut down and
there would just be so many losses
in terms of that extended protracted
writing process that i decided to put it
out as a podcast
and the question was how can i make this
as easy as possible for myself because i
knew it was going to be [ __ ] hard i
knew the whole thing was going to be
excruciating on multiple levels and so i
constantly ask myself how can i make
this easier how can i make this easier
don't do a book do a podcast how can i
make the podcast easier don't make it a
monologue make it a conversation
how can i make it easier don't commit to
publishing it
have the conversation record it and
reserve the right to
never have anyone listen to it etc etc
etc
and both in preparation for that and
after that spent a lot of time
i know i haven't directly answered your
question but this is getting around to
it
sure both before and after that decided
that i needed
and wanted to have safety nets in place
and to prepare myself for this to
prepare my team
to set rules such that i would be
as likely as possible to hold my footing
because i've been re-traumatized by
exploring this in the past and
and i attempted to do writing related to
this and it caused severe problems in my
life for
for many months so i i was prepared to
be destabilized and i wanted to decrease
the odds
of it being catastrophic so i i began
to commit to certain practices and also
sessions with people
one of whom is named jim detmer d th
mer he has been on this podcast and
a very
important piece of the work that i've
done with him
has been related to identifying
unsaids uncomplete or uncompleted
and so on that represent withholds
that would include grudges and trying to
engineer some form of closure and the
closure could just be
letting it go in some very visceral
sense in some way that feels complete
it's the easiest way to to take things
off your to-do list
or to finish things on your to-do list
rather is to remove them from your to-do
list
so you're you're actually catching me at
a an unusual point in my life if you
look at it from the perspective
zooming out of the rest of my life i
have had a life full of grudges
and full of anger and it just so happens
that you are catching me at a point
we're having this conversation at a
point where i've done
since this podcast came out if i'm
remembering correctly
last september september 2020 and for
people who want that story you can go to
tim dot blog forward slash trauma
i won't belabor it here it's intense and
it's not for everyone
but for several months prior to that up
to now
when we're recording as i look at the
calendar in late february
this has been constant work do i still
have grudges i think the answer is yes
so let me try to if it still makes sense
sort of do a quick search function
actually i want to ask you before we do
that just
what is the process that you have gone
through
i certainly don't mean to retell the
story because
what you're saying is so valid about
that when we have to tell and retell and
retell
sure traumatic stories but what what
have you done to
close loops i should specify and i'm
glad you're you're asking
that the work was far beyond
the aspects of my life or grudges
related to the trauma and
that i think and a lot of this is
speculation almost all therapy is
speculation if we're being honest with
ourselves
that i had many at the time
adaptive responses to the abuse and
there were other examples of abuse that
i didn't even get into in that episode
but
i had certain adaptive responses to that
to survive as a child who
could not defend himself and
had had very little agency right and
those adaptive responses
at some point became maladaptive
they outlived their usefulness and they
became very
unhelpful at best and very damaging
and self-destructive in other cases and
i think that rage and anger and
a mindset that really defaulted to
offenses the best defense which i still
believe
on a lot of levels and that's actually
uh you know a line that i attribute to a
lot of the best athletes i admire but
i what that meant is that anger which on
some level
i think in that offense and that attack
default was a byproduct of
the in some ways the trauma that i
experienced
but the problems that it created and the
grudges
that stuck for long periods of time
were not directly related to the
traumatic event if that makes sense does
that make sense
well i think it does because what you're
saying is that you're in this position
and i no therapist i you need to be
careful but it sounds to me that you're
in this defenseless position
you are coming up with not just stories
about it
when you're so young i mean i haven't
said you barely understand
stories of what the world is and you're
still trying to make sense of this
evil and this unprotectedness and
all of that you take on these new
this way of being in the world and part
of it
sounds like this is too strong for what
you've said but it's like almost a
predatorial
positioning it's not like i am going to
destroy you
but it's a sense of threat i remember a
therapist i went to
describing it this way they said there's
two
states you can be in you can be in a
what is this state
and then you can be in a what the hell
is this state um her words not mine
yeah let me if if i could just bookmark
that for a second so i would say
you know i certainly wasn't i'm not sure
if this was
i'm hearing it correctly but you know i
was not predatory
i was highly weaponized if i felt
i needed to retaliate or defend myself
so it was very much in
in the vein of bruce lee right and i'm
gonna
mangle this but he he has a quote along
the lines of
you know you graze my skin i pound your
flesh you pound my
flesh i break your bones you break my
bones i take your life
that was the mentality and you know put
another way
there's a major
holdridge retired this is u.s marine
corps
as a quote and it's sometimes it's
entirely appropriate to kill a fly with
a sledgehammer
and i think that that was my feeling
right if someone
inflicted pain on me i felt it was my
obligation to return it upon them
tenfold a hundred fold
and you know i think there's actually
still a place for that but it
as a default it wastes a tremendous
[ __ ] amount of energy
uh so i not not to take you off track i
want it to allow you to continue
now it's just not off track it's it is
important
there's a big difference i think you're
right between predatorial and
highly militarized you know it's
more like a trigger ready to trigger
you're like don't mess with me like i'm
fine i'm good here but if you mess with
me
i am coming after you i mean at least it
makes sense to me
this is a minor example but i remember
when i was growing up in england and i
was walking down the street one time
just in the downtown
absolutely doing nothing but walking
and two people walking towards me i
didn't even think even register
one of them that's probably about 12 at
the time he was 16
ish i would say two of them just kind of
almost arm in the arm together and then
he just
punched me in the face just straight in
the nose just like broke my nose just
hard and i was so shocked
and i turned around and they were just
laughing and just walked off and that
was it i didn't have there was nothing
in me
ready to respond to that there was
nothing i was prepared for
but i remember years later as an adult i
mean i hadn't even thought about the
experience but somebody they didn't
hit me but they went to kind of pretend
hit me when i was an adult when i was in
a mall
almost the same situation two people
walking towards me and i just
lost it you know i didn't actually have
a fight or anything but i just
was like so ready to
because of that pre-programming and that
experience and of course it's not very
helpful to have
that pre-programming uh you know
in there but it's an example of how when
we've had an experience in the past and
it can as you already said outlive its
usefulness
anyway that's what i've i'm hearing you
is like yeah i
i was ready to fight you know i couldn't
protect myself before but i was going to
protect myself going forward yeah that's
the thrust of it
and do i have grudges i am sure i have a
whole
laundry list of grudges i'm just
struggling to pull up one specifically
right now but i still want to go back i
know i'm bothering you with this but
how what did you do you said that you've
been doing things to remove them
and i just want to know because that
seems like such a
valid and relevant thing how do you
close up
these loops and these things that have
been dragging what have you actually
done
well there were there are many things so
if there were say commitments that i
hadn't completed
and that was creating some type of
exacting some
cost on my system then i would either
take a look and make a list and decide
which of them
i would complete or
cancel or renegotiate in some fashion so
i could
sort of wipe that category clean
of any debts that were consuming
any bandwidth then you would have
for instance withholds meaning unsaids
things i haven't said to people so if
someone consistently does something that
is driving me [ __ ] bonkers or
more accurately and this is also
language
modification that i would do that i am
using to make myself bonkers
and so assuming some locus of control
for how you respond to these things so
not
a b and c is making me anxious or
pissing me off but i am making myself
anxious because
abc has been a shift that's that's
somewhat
separate but also interrelated having a
lot of uncomfortable conversations
using frameworks fairly simple
templates similar to non-violent
communication
and having what jim would call clearing
conversations
to take those things that are unsaid
and say them in some fashion so that
those aren't constituting some type of
of loop right these imaginary arguments
that at least
certainly i am a master at formulating
incredibly compelling arguments and then
if they said this i would say this and
then if they said that i would say that
and
oh my god i would just rip their faces
off and debate and
what a mighty victory that would be i
mean these types of fantasies
that consume incredible
amounts of calories you know incredible
numbers of calories
i wanted to remove those
from the program and that entailed
having a lot of conversations
to be truthful end up being fewer
conversations than
i expected to have a significant impact
on energy reserves because fatigue i've
had a lifelong battle with
chronic fatigue for many reasons
including two severe bouts with lyme
disease growing up on long island but
energy management has become more and
more important to me than time
management they're
related but energy management like that
is the
parent resource that determines all
other resources in the same way that i
think it was maya angelou who said
i might be misattributing so somebody
will be able to find this quote but
you mentioned courage you know courage
is the mother virtue
every other virtue at its testing point
depends on courage
and i say that simply
to underscore the fact that much like
anything else
there might be 10 conversations you feel
like you
need to have or should have to close
open loops
and really it's two or three of them
that are going to
deliver 99 of the relief and
i found that to be true those are a few
of the approaches
and people can find the clearing
conversation format
which can be a bit stilted and
odd on the
conscious leadership group website
conscious.is
you would also be well served just by
looking
at various templates for non-violent
communication
and separately used
quite a bit of the questions
offered in the work by byron katie
which i highly recommend to people for
stress testing
beliefs around some of the grudges
or some of the unsaids and in in several
cases
just came to the conclusion that the
core beliefs
that i was using to enable myself to be
so pissed off
actually were very hard to defend
and i was like oh what like like what
well
uh for instance there have been a few
examples
in my life where entitlement has carried
a huge
charge for me there are very few things
in life that bother me as much as
what i perceive to be entitlement
self-righteousness also probably equally
irritating to me or that i use to annoy
myself
like i just uh i i just i
generally have very poor response to
both of those things and
so my general belief in life
is and amelia boone is actually the one
who who uttered this quote she's a
multiple time world champion
in uh world toughest mudder and
and also an attorney and just all around
superstar in many respects and her her
quote
i believe it was in tools of titans
originally when i asked her what she
would put on a
billboard is no one owes you anything
like just
just start with that assumption and
you'll be much better off in life
and i agree with that so entitlement
let's just say
my belief is and i don't want to put
words
in byron katie's mouth but if we take a
a belief to be a thought we take to be
true
if my belief is let's just say my belief
is and
this is a real example but i'm let's say
my belief is
greg is entitled right and like you
if my belief were you are entitled
that's not my belief but let's just say
it was like my belief is you're entitled
because
i helped you with a b and c and then i
asked you for help with d
and you not only said you couldn't help
but did it in a way that i
i took is very rude never happened but
let's just say that's the case
no but but in that example what i rather
suspect
is you are describing many interactions
you actually have
you know i don't actually expect
reciprocity when i help someone so i i
really
this actually happens the other way
around more often than not
where someone has done me some favor i
didn't ask for with a book launch and
then comes to me with some huge ask and
gets extremely pissed off when i say no
with a clear boundary
so it's more frequent the other way
around but sure but i'll give you
let's make it a real example so i'm not
going to use names but
there are cases where i feel like i've
gone
above and beyond to
help people when they've asked for help
not related to book launches or anything
like that
and then there's a something i consider
to be very small
very very small with respect to an ask
and i'm given a no but it's delivered in
a way that i take to be
unnecessarily rude when my out when my
ask is delivered very
in my life from my perspective very
politely
etc etc you interpret it as a slight you
feel slighted
yes and then i'll have a sentence like
so and so is entitled
so the way you might work with that in
byron katie's the work
is you would ask questions like and i
don't find the first two as helpful as
they might be otherwise
there are lots of different ways to do
this but is it true number one number
two
can i absolutely for sure know this to
be true
and i'm gonna get these slightly off but
the gist is what's important
number three who am i and how do i feel
when i believe this to be true
and then who would i be and how would i
feel if i did not take this to be true
okay those those questions three and
four i find very powerful
and then the next step that i tend to
take is what people would call
turnarounds and turnarounds
involve playing with language and then
forcing yourself as a thought experiment
to come up with
evidence to support new statements for
instance
let's just say i'm not going to use your
name we'll say mark
let's just say it's a mark mark is
entitled
we could turn that around by saying mark
is not entitled
you could even use the opposite like
mark is generous and
then you force yourself to come up with
and it's best to do this in writing
three to five points
pieces of evidence that you would use if
you were in in
a debate and trying to make that case
then you could have
not mark as entitled but i am entitled
and then you come up with three
to five and three to five is arbitrary
but it's just a nice kind of clean range
then you could go on to perform
multiple other turnarounds and by the
time you've done that if you're really
committing to doing it seriously with an
open mind
it starts to diffuse a lot of reactivity
so that would be an example of doing the
work and all that's available
for free online if people go to to buyer
and katie's
website yeah i mean what you've just
done is you have given us specific
tools as always but around
this subject of decluttering and getting
out all of
specifically we've been talking about
grudges but pain and all these things
that we hold on to
and uh and how they cluster us up
i mean i'm not gonna necessarily have
you answer this question it could be
rhetorical but like what percentage of
your energy
has been spent in the course of your
life
oh god it's going to be bad yes go ahead
no actually if you now that i'm asking i
kind of do want the answer i said it was
rhetorical then i changed
my mind like what do you think it
actually is well
what yeah what personality energy has
been spent
holding grudges having stories about
people that may or not may not be true
just all of that clutter that we're
holding we're carrying we're processing
we're
everywhere we go there it is with us
it's not in a sense making the email
we're working on next
harder but of course it is because it's
using up all of this
hardware ram in our supercomputer brain
and soul
keeping us from being able to do the
thing that we really came here to do
i would add i'm going to answer the
question it i would add to that that
it's even more damaging
in my mind because you develop habits of
constructing certain types of stories
and those pathways and i'm not going to
make a
neurobiological case for this i'm sure
one could
but suffice to say if we
become habitually good
at creating stories about being victims
then it will become easier and easier to
later construct
stories about us being the victim if we
create stories around certain people
having certain traits
and we reinforce those over and over
again and we have selection bias and
begin to pick out all of the evidence
points that condemn these people it
becomes
easier and easier over time and
therefore the habit perpetuates the bad
habit if that makes sense
so to answer your question like how much
of my life energy oh god i mean
if we went from if we just took like tim
from 15 to 35 let's just say
i shudder to even hazard a guess 60
i mean 70 it's high i mean just in terms
of
ongoing stories that
the vast majority of the time are never
acted upon
or most likely don't reflect
reality because i'm not actually
engaging i'm not clearing these
conversations i'm not
fill in the blank it's an embarrassingly
high number
it's astonishing that i've been able to
get anything done honestly and not just
anything right i mean even in the period
you're describing
you still will have appeared
well were highly productive but i mean
that's the kind of rebate and why
effortless state is
such a vital part of really what i
as i now understand better about this
a different way to live and to work it's
like it's not the task itself
that's hard in many instances it's all
of
this stuff all of this rubbish
that's slowing us down that's getting in
the way that's making relationships
twice as hard sometimes ten times as
hard as they need to be because of all
of this clutter
as we learn to remove that we start to
find i mean
what kind of productivity tip
are we talking about here this is better
than any other productivity hack
that you can ever come up with a 70 60
70
return of your capability and
suddenly back i mean that's like a
massive upgrade so
save me greg mcewen what do i do what do
we do if the listeners are like
i need some principles or something god
save us
it is a huge cost and i feel like i'm in
probably a better place than i've ever
been at this point in time i mean
knock on wood so don't jinx myself but
there's still incredible room for
improvement i mean if we look at
all skill development along the spectrum
of
let's just say unconscious incompetence
conscious incompetence
conscious competence then unconscious
competence right where you can really
execute without having to analyze and
crunch everything
cognitively i feel like i'm still very
much in the conscious incompetence realm
i mean i'm just like
oh my god like look at this
circus uh this like panopticon
of fantasy horrors that i create for
myself
every [ __ ] day this is ludicrous you
know now i'm just
aware of the clown car that's driving
through my head all day
so what what what
are some tools yes what are some tools
or if tools isn't the right term
principles and anything that we can that
we can start to experiment with
well one story that comes to mind and i
i may have actually shared this last
time but
did i talk about the moment when i was
staring back at myself in the
stormtrooper costume
yes you did mention uh you did mention
the stormtrooper we could we can revisit
it and you mentioned
let's revisit very briefly i mean the
point was that i'm suddenly
looking at myself in a stormtrooper
costume in the mirror in the
this is an expensive movie quality
suit and in that moment i'm just like
what
am i doing like why am i standing here
how did this just happen it's not just
the same context because you're not on
like fifth avenue spinning a sign
selling used watches or something this
was for halloween
you had always thought this was what you
wanted and
now you're let's just say 40 years old
something like that i don't know
exactly exactly i suddenly how am i here
well
as i'm pausing to think about it i
realize well it was
when return of the jedi came out yeah
they were talking
30 plus years before that
my older brother spencer had said to me
well wouldn't it be so cool to have like
a movie quality stormtrooper costume
and i'm like young enough impressionable
enough and of course all the hype around
the movie i love that movie and
i just held on to that for 30 years
that's a lightweight example
given the the weight of the things we've
been talking about but
it still illustrates how long things can
stay with you and as i'm standing there
i'm like there's no part of me that
actually wants this consciously it's
just all subconscious
and so that became a shorthand for anna
and i that if i get caught up on
something if i get fixated
on something she will say look is it is
this a storm trooper
and even that question is is very
helpful for me
symbolically because being focused
on something is a super strength that's
a super skill
it's incredibly valuable unless you're
focused on the wrong thing
and then it's like a classic example of
making your life
much harder than it needs to be because
you're pursuing something now in this
case
30 years yes maybe this is pretty
trivial example although
if you add up the actual energy that was
being dripped by drip over 30 years it's
still an immense amount
but to just ask that about other things
we have other goals that we have
are the we've emphasized grudges but
it's not the only type of
clutter that can get into us but we can
just
ask is this something that we need
anymore could we just let go of it would
that be possible
to release this question for you just to
get concrete
so during your experience with the with
eve
medical crisis with your daughter did
you apply this to anything
specific you can share i mean the thing
that comes to mind when you say that
is perhaps the most practical skill for
getting into the effortless
state amidst that crisis
uh was gratitude and i know i almost
don't want to say it like that because
people think oh i've done gratitude we
know
but what i learned about gratitude was
this if you focus
on what you have you gain what you lack
and if you focus
on what you lack you lose what you have
oh that's good can you say that again
please yeah if you focus on what
you have you gain what you lack
if you focus on what you lack
you lose what you have that's
outstanding
and so one of the practices that i
learned at that time
but have codified a little better now
and this is you know this is classic bj
fogg
tiny habit habit recipe
just for people who don't know bj fox so
bj fogg is a
fascinating guy writer professor i don't
know if he's still teaching at stanford
has uh has done a lot of interesting
fascinating work and practical work
related to habit formation and
behavioral change and things like that
yeah he's so great i mean i just had him
on the what's the central podcast and we
did this really interesting intervention
where we talked about what was essential
for him
he identified it wanted to have a
three-day weekend he's never done that
he's kind of works all weekend and he
doesn't
and then halfway through after we
identified it all i said okay well man
you you're the
the habit king man so that now you have
to solve that for me like
you know what you want to do now now
teach me how to do it anyway it was a
really fun conversation
so coming from that this is this is the
specific habit recipe as he would call
them
i have a recipe right you say after i x
i will
why that's the format and so i started
saying okay well after i complain
i will say something i'm thankful for
and
here's what i learned immediately was i
complain a lot more than i realized
yeah i think of myself as a positive
person and and i actually think i am
even now but my goodness i just
these just subtle complaints all the
time you just see
what's you know going wrong with
something and so you can have so many
good things happening but you focus on
something that isn't going right and so
that was the first thing i noticed the
second thing i noticed was how
fast you can change the mood if you
either
say something you're thankful for
afterwards or you catch yourself and do
it anyway
so even if i was saying something i was
thankful for not even i'm thankful for
you or something you have done
the people around me would instantly
light up
it was a different motion so it had an
immediate effect it was
one of the fastest things i have found
for getting back into the effortless
state and so we've started all sorts of
habits in in
in the family with this somebody's
complaining i'll say okay that's fine
you've got to do you know three things
you're thankful for you know you've got
to put the energy back that you just
took out
and you know you can imagine four
teenagers that necessarily love this
game they must love that
yeah but but jack my son you know one
time
actually often they will just do it
sincerely and so on but one time he's
just like oh okay fine
i am so thankful that dad wants to play
this you know this dumb game with me you
know
and it made everybody laugh and then
suddenly we were all already back in the
state and we went on and did the other
things we're thankful for i mean
literally
to me this type of gratitude and
thankfulness is
so powerful i mean i used to think of it
as a soft principle it's like made of
titanium it's so powerful
and you can even have a bad attitude
about it and it still works
and so i mean that i mean we've done all
sorts of things to build on that and so
here we have all this
stress and challenge that we have of
covid and being isolated because of eve
we weren't just isolated for six months
we were on complete lockdown i mean like
everyone else is out but we just i can't
even risk because of the
the treatment she was going through one
of the things we did is we started them
it's the star chart game i mean it
doesn't sound so exciting but it's
you gather together you come up with a
prize you all want some something you're
going to do or something you're going to
buy or something
fun it doesn't have to be that expensive
and and then there's a series of spaces
that we we will catch
each other doing the right thing and if
you do you say okay well you start for
you and anyone can give them to anyone
most of them are still anna and i but
even this kids can give them to each
other
and you go and draw on when the star
shot is full you get that thing you get
to do that experience whatever it's so
positive and you can't take a star away
there's no none of that there's no
downside here
it's all upside in and actually what
again might sound
trivial is i think anything but and to
give a little context of why it's so
powerful
barbara fredrickson i called this the
broaden and build theory
what she extrapolated which i think is
genius is that
we don't have good things happen to us
and therefore have good emotions
she says you have positive emotion and
that leads
through a process to good things so the
place to start
again i suppose this is confirming of
what you know the idea of effortless
state first
is that if you can get positive emotion
going
then a whole series of upward momentum
happens so
she identified it this way she said well
first it's the positive emotions so
you're feeling good gratitude you can do
that that's one of them
and then you start to have more
optionality more options of what you can
do and what possibilities exist and what
good things are here
and so because you're have options
it means that you are more likely to
connect with other people and so you
build relationships and so
why she calls it the broaden and build
theory is that as you're in this upward
momentum this positive cycle you're
actually increasing capability
therefore are better able to handle
whatever the next challenge is
or as i suppose it is even in the
pandemic but there'll be something else
afterwards
and she contrasts that with as soon as
you get into negative emotion
that leads to a reduction of options
right we know that
it's fight flight freeze fall down it's
just very few options that we're going
to have
or what effect does that have on your
relationships it strains them all
what does that do it weakens your whole
system for whatever the next challenge
is
and so this sort of doom loop can take
place and so
i really see at the pivot point
being within this choice to see
what is right here a little bit like
putting on i'm not a fly fisher actually
but i've heard and done the research and
i'm
confident this is true that something
you can do if you want to be a great fly
fisher
is that you can wear polarized
sunglasses and it's something about the
way that the
the lines are in a polarized set of
sunglasses that they
kill off the way the sun reflects on the
water and so the
impact of this is that you can see the
fish under the water
fish were always there but you couldn't
see them before and now you can and
that's really what this
habit recipe this specific thing this
leaning into gratitude in a very
deliberate way conscious way starts to
do you start to see
all the assets that are there so then
you can build on them then you can do
something with them what
good is here and to keep shifting back
into that gear
uh whether you're dealing with crisis or
just even in normal life
and i'm not always great at this i still
fall into this if i
leave this conversation it will be easy
to find something that's wrong to
complain
but if i take this other path and of
course if i do that it's all
predictable you start on the downward
cycle but if i say
what is going right here and i catch
someone doing the right thing
it just sparks the whole thing positive
and and really which do you think is
easier
is it easier to be on a downward loop or
in this upward momentum and so this is
one of the reasons i see this as being
such an important practice
for effortless state with the concentric
circles
actually before i get back to the
concentric circles i first want to say
you're inspiring me to
revisit the 21 day no
complaint experiment that i did many
many years ago i wrote a blog post about
it
which was inspired by will bowen i think
that's how you say his name
who was a preacher or a minister in
kansas city who gave his congregation
purple bracelets
and every time they complained they had
to switch arms
and start the clock again with the aim
of getting to 21 days of no complaining
and he wrote a book called the complaint
free world i want to say
and i did that experiment and just like
you mentioned number one you notice oh
my god
i am just the poster boy for complaining
this is outrageous
and secondly how quickly you begin to
reap the benefits
of decreasing your complaining it's
truly remarkable
so just with that said concentric
circles why
is the effortless outside of effortless
state which is the center you have
effortless action
and then effortless results why are the
actions
separate from the results
oh well effortless action is
to do with saying okay if i want a
result
one time how can i make it
easier to achieve like this project this
thing
an example for me in my own family is to
start there
my son chose when he was about 12 he
decided okay i want to be an eagle scout
and his goal was to do it by the time he
turned 14 which is you know that's a bit
of a stretch
and you know we went on this journey
together and and we
we did it other than the dreaded
final not just even the final project
which was you know
fairly big thing he had to build this
180 foot fence and bring
people from the community 40 people go
and do it on a day and it was like
it was actually pretty fantastic but
then what is is dreaded is the final
report
and there are people i know who have
done everything else and then they
don't get the final report and they put
it off
seriously it happened to somebody i knew
he'd done everything but that final
report and he finally put it in
37. no you have to do it by the time you
turn 18 and he got it one week
afterwards and so he never got an eagle
scout because they were
they were 100 sticklers on this which
i suppose they have learned they have to
be because if you procrastinate for
three years you could do it for 30 and
because it
and so so they have this cutter point so
so we start moving into that category
you know we're not it's weeks it's not
months or years but weeks we just start
working oh yeah we got to do this and
it just starts feeling overly burdened
and so then
i literally sat down with him and was
like okay how can we make this
effortless
how can we make this so we can actually
get the thing done
there were a series of questions that we
followed with that i mean one is
what does done look like just like
actually naming it well we are taking
a binder to the scout office and
delivering it and they sign
that it is done that's how we'll know
it's done okay well what
are the minimum steps required to do it
not you know some people want to go the
extra mile but they're not even going
the first mile and that was that's sort
of what we were doing
we're like oh i mean we had seen and i'm
not knocking this i mean i
we have seen some amazing really
unbelievable final projects
reports rather the writer we see them in
wooden boxes and
gorgeous and just fine it is incredible
you know like the rolls royce of
reports and i think that was a big part
of why we couldn't make any progress
we're just like ah we just don't have
the sinners we just
we don't have energy for this we and so
we say okay we say what's the minimum
number of steps
we looked at exactly what it asked us to
do
okay we need to have the photos printed
up print it up we're gonna have them
written on you don't even have to write
essays on them we're going to have the
minimum number of descriptions he needs
to do the work
and a minimum number of steps possible
so we did that okay
next question what is the very first
most
obvious step to doing it now the risk of
these kinds of projects is you're
worrying about the thousandth step
and you haven't actually physically
taken the first one
and okay we first physical step is we
need to
actually get a three ring binder you
know we're gonna get that and we had one
we have to go and find one in the house
and guess it that is the first step
and in that way just actually started
doing the tiny
one step at a time minimum things
required to get there
and that reminds me of a story we sort
of know some of this story
many people have heard part of it but i
i went and interviewed the person behind
it is uh
his name is this really is really his
name is his mic evangelist
and that's an amazing name isn't that
amazing and he's
he's in silicon valley he's yeah mike
evangelist
he was involved in dvd burning
before it was a mass thing these are
like
thousand dollar machines professional
equipment this is uh
it's a thousand page manual to learn how
to use it
the dvd burner for the best system right
back in the day exactly
and then they're trying to work out a
bit more affordable way of doing it and
so on in the on the cutting edge and so
apple reaches out to them and says look
maybe we can do something here maybe we
can buy the company and so on and
they do a deal and they bring them in
and they they want the software that
they've been creating and so on so
they're given
a couple of weeks they know they're
going to meet with steve jobs and they
have a couple of weeks
to like simplify this thing it's going
to go on the mac that's the idea and so
they have to try
and so they take this thousand page by
and they reduce it and reduce it they
take all this complex stuff and they
reduce it and reduce and they're proud
of what they have and they think okay
this is
so so much simpler than we had before
and they go into the meeting and this is
the part
people know but the backstory is really
important so steve comes to the meeting
and they have all of their slides
they've got everything ready for the
presentation and they're talking about
it and they're discussing
and as steve starts talking they start
to get more and more embarrassed about
their presentation
and what they're going to do and finally
steve just walks up to the whiteboard
and he just goes look
this is the software there's going to be
one button
you're going to draw your file into it
and it says burn
that's it that's the application we want
to build
and that is what they built and that is
what went in but here's the point and i
really like this from mike evangelist he
said he said sitting there
he learned he was doing simplification
wrong
he was going from the complex to the
simple
well what he really needed to do this is
his phrase start with zero
you've got to start with zero and say
what are the minimum number of steps to
get to completion
and i like that story but that's really
that's really what we were doing
with jack and his project is like not
what other people doing and let's go
smaller it's like let's start with zero
or the minimum number of steps to do it
and what you want is completion and if
you don't complete it then it's not done
i mean i'm saying something so circular
but
you've got to get it done and so that is
its own achievement and if you don't get
it done
perpetually because you either have too
many steps involved or because
you don't take the first action or i
have to share this
it's one of my favorite stories i came
across in the research it's have you
heard of the story of the vassa
i don't think so can you spell that for
me it might be a
queen the queen's english that's
throwing me off w-a-s-a
vasa the vasa w is and it starts with a
v
v-a-s-s-o did i say that no
w-w-a-s-a
definitely don't know that story please
continue
okay i'm going to read the whole thing
to you because the details really matter
is that is that okay with you
you're like you're the first blender to
hear about this
i'm excited here we go well you're not
the first to hear about it you first to
hear about the way i write about it here
we go
400 years ago gustav ii the king of
sweden
saw the vital need to upgrade his armada
of ships he wanted to protect the people
from the growing naval powers that
surrounded him
his attention was drawn to building a
giant military warship
and he found a shipbuilder henrik
heibertson tasked him to build
what became known as the vasa i've said
it wrong it is vasa
vasa which which wasn't because i knew
the stories because
i can't understand the queen's english
please continue this
this project was of utmost importance to
king gustaf so much
so that he allowed a whole forest of a
thousand trees to provide the lumber for
the project he opened the royal coffers
too
uh he assured haberson that he would
have an almost
unlimited budget to complete the project
successfully
unfortunately the king did not have a
clear vision
of what the final product would look
like or rather he kept changing his
vision of what the final product would
look like at first the ship was to be
108 feet long
with 32 cannons on deck later the length
was changed to 120 feet
even though the lumber had already been
cut to the original specifications but
no sooner had henrik's team made the
necessary adjustments that the target
shifted again
this time the king decided the ship
needed to be 135 feet long
the cannon requirements changed as well
instead of 32 cannons in a single row
he asked for 36 cannons in two rows plus
another
12 small cameras 48 mortars and 10 more
similar caliber weapons
tremendous effort was exhausted by some
400 people to make this happen but even
as they approach completion the king
changed his mind again
asked for 64 large cannons instead the
stress of the news
is said to have given henrique a fatal
heart attack
still the endless project continued this
time under henrik's assistant hein
jacobson
budgets continued to escalate the effort
continued to expand and the king
continued changing the end goal
in an utterly non-essential edition for
a gunship he asked
for some 700 or 8 sculptures which would
take a team
of expert sculptors more than two years
to complete
to be attached to the sides the bulwark
and the transom of the ship
and so it was on august 10 1628
the vasa left stockholm port for its
maiden voyage
still unfinished and before it been
properly tested to ensure it could
survive the conditions of the high seas
meanwhile the king had found the time to
plan a celebration to commemorate the
expedition
there were fireworks there were foreign
diplomats there was pageantry
and as the ship sailed away the gun
ports were open and the guns were
pointing out so that they could fire a
salute to the dignitaries on shore
then suddenly a gust of wind caught the
sails of the ship
causing the massive vessel to tilt
severely over to one side
as the cannons tipped into the sea water
entered in through the gun ports
despite a strenuous all-out effort on
the part of the crew
water almost instantly flooded into the
gun deck and
into the hole further destabilizing the
ship
tragically it took just 50 minutes for
the vasa
to completely sink taking 53 crew
members with it
they died less than three quarters of a
mile from the shore and so it was
the most expensive naval project in
sweden's history sailed less than one
mile
before being buried in the sea all
because the king had made the project
almost impossible
to safely complete by constantly
redefining what
done looks like that is the story of the
passo sounds like a lot of
software projects it does and it sounds
like
just so many projects and so that's
really what part of what effortless
action is about it's saying look
if you have a thing you want to do you
want to do it one time
you want to actually get it done and you
don't want to
kill yourself doing it there's a series
of things that you can do i've covered
two or three of them
you can pace yourself you can make sure
that you know that's what that
section of the book is really about your
question was
how does that distinguish itself from
effortless results and that's
literally my favorite thing in my
research for effortless was this final
section which is a little too bad
because
sometimes people don't you know get to
the end of a book
and so so you know it's uh
effortless results right the difference
is this
action is about the thing one time
that's
by definition is a linear
result you're getting it one time you
put the effort in once
and you get the result once effortless
results is all about
residual results how can you construct
things
that produce you put the effort in once
you might even put a little more effort
in
than if you just want the result once
but you put the effort in
because you're going to get the result
10 times 100 times 1 000 times
i mean actually it sounds like total
exaggeration
to say a million times but actually it's
not there's plenty of examples
where people have constructed systems
that keep
producing results so very many times
over again and again
and really why effortless results i
think is
such an exciting subject for me and my
favorite thing in this is because i
realized
how many things i was doing
were linear results one time you do it
you go you do a keynote you've built the
system to make that as effortless as
possible
the results you know seem to be good
but it's done one time you got one time
impact
and one travel and one thing and and
that doesn't make it a bad thing of
course
but it's an example of like me just
discovering like why am i doing
anything that only produces results one
time
i've got to change this ratio massively
and i mean this is
for me personally i mean one of the
things i came away with done
simultaneously to the book is
is launch an academy right
essentialism.com and the whole reason i
did it is i'm just
like look build it once do it once and
it returns
10 years from now or even more than that
i mean a friend of mine
i would say colleague and mentor to me
stephen covey and he passed away
unfortunately a few years ago
but his impact has gone on significantly
and the reason for that
wasn't by chance it's because he knew
the risk because one of his friends
and mentors had died young and he
he took it all with him so it was
because of that that stephen says okay
well i'm going to i'm going to write the
seven habits because then
it can exist beyond me i'm going to
build a company he didn't
really himself want to do that
work but he built it so that the system
would continue on and on into the future
the residual results
is an area of so much upside possibility
uh it just reminds me of uh benjamin
hardy who i just had on the what's the
central podcast and he
was sharing this principle of who
not how and it really hit me as a such a
great succinct summary of this
idea that we ought to be thinking not
just how do i do a thing and not just
hit a wall and feel well i've got to go
in the long journey to figure out how to
do this myself but just who has already
solved this who already knows
how to do this and that was one of my
favorite parts of
researching effortless was coming across
a rule that
warren buffett uses when he's hiring
people he's deciding who he's going
to work with who he's going to partner
with the best people in the world he's
trying to find and he uses three
principles he says it's integrity
it's intelligence and it's initiative
and he adds that if you don't have the
integrity then the other two can
actually be a problem for you but
that really has stood with me when we
think about
who not how and then specifically using
what i now call the three
eyes to assess who would be a great
person to work with and so anyway just
offer that as a
thought about how to produce even more
effortless results as you try to take
this next
journey uh with the podcast itself it
also makes me
just reflect on how many of these
principles are on some level embedded
into your thinking if you just shift the
time
frame from short-term rewards or
short-term outcomes to long-term
outcomes and
brings to mind something that my friend
naval robocon who's been on the podcast
several times has said which
actually i should say more accurately
typed
his twitter account is very popular at
naval and aval
and it's it's along the lines of if you
wouldn't
work with them for a lifetime don't work
with them for five minutes
and oh man that's good and it just
checks
so many boxes that you could view as
discrete problems to be solved but if
you
just keep that overarching principle in
mind even if there are
exceptions right i mean perhaps if
you're an airbnb and you break something
you need to fix like you're not going to
work
with this plumber for the rest of your
life necessarily
but those are the exceptions that prove
the rule as opposed to
around well i just think that puts into
my mind this idea of very
long-term thinking again and the
importance of it one of my favorite
examples of this
residual thinking where you aren't just
thinking about yourself but beyond
yourself
is stephen l richards and his wife who
decided well we want to try and take
time out every summer go on a
family vacation and so on and of course
most people
have that type of thought but theirs
grew into something different where they
said well what if we could choose a
place
one time that every single summer
afterwards we wouldn't have to go
through
that journey of well where are we going
to go and what are the dates and
and so on and what started as
what might sound not such a profound
question or decision
has gone on and on they chose this one
location
and here they are this is i was talking
to their grandson
who himself is now elderly this has gone
on now for 95 years that they are long
since passed
their grandchildren have started passing
away
and so they still have great great
grandchildren who will meet at various
times through the summer so it's the
same location
people have invested in different cabins
and all of this and he said
he said on any given day through a whole
period like the whole three-month summer
if you go to that location you'll find
between 30 and 100
people that come from the same stephen
richards
that started to me that's a powerful
example of
effortless results the residual results
deciding for a long time
into the future and stephen richards for
those who don't know is
was a prominent leader in the lds church
in the
latter-day saints church is that right
is that the the the correct stephen l
richards that i'm thinking of
yes no you're absolutely right and and
his
grandson is stephen r covey
and it was his brother john covey that i
was speaking to
that told me that story and so it's
really um amazing to see that sort of
intergenerational impact and for those
people
who have bookmarked the gordon b
hinckley book that you mentioned earlier
i was able to
surreptitiously tap on my phone silently
which is actually a trick i
put my phone for those people who are
experimenting with podcasting
i keep my iphone on do not disturb mode
so that if there are items that pop up
in the conversation
i can search them on my phone without
recording any audible noise
teachings of the presidents of the
church by gordon b hinckley was the book
within which i believe
there is the essay that you alluded to
earlier
in this conversation thinking of books
i had to wonder when i read your first
book you know essentialism it's like
well how do you
edit how ruthless must you be when you
are editing a book
called essentialism i mean that's
setting high expectations for the copy
editors and the
editors and certainly for the the author
in this case you so in this second book
so effortless was there anything that
any darlings that you
had to leave behind anything that was
left on the cutting room floor
that was particularly difficult to leave
out
you know there's so much that you go
through
in the editing process and some ways i
feel like there's two
three whole books that were written and
discarded
on the way to this final project and
most of those i feel really good about
but there is one that
still just i always wonder whether
i made the right decision or not with it
it's a particularly powerful story
of a mother who is
with her very sick son
at the very what turned out to be the
very end of his life and she was sitting
next to him in the bed
and then as literally as life is sort of
training out of him
she climbs up into the bed just to be
right next to him
knowing that the end is really close and
hears him say and these turn out to be
his very last words
sort of in that in between phase when
you're still here but somehow
not fully he just said it's all so
simple
mom it's all so simple and to me that
sort of
message that sort of moment
is of great value because i think that
the spirit of that is just look at
anything you're doing that's making life
more complicated than it needs to be
where you're overthinking it where
you're over straining where you're over
exerting
where you're overthinking and
you may find the very
thing that's going to help you move
forward you know it may be as simple it
may be
as easy as that it's
all so simple just pausing on that
it's so easy
in a sense difficult in other senses to
default straining
you know to to feel like you're not
doing enough if you are not
straining if you're not redlining if
you're not pushing to failure in some
way
it's all so simple that's a great story
i mean it would make a great mantra for
that matter and
that in my mind sort of begets a
question that i may have asked you
in the first conversation that we had on
this podcast but i'll ask it again just
in case there's a different answer
or if you want to add another answer
the billboard my listeners my long-term
listeners
are probably sick of hearing this but
sometimes it sometimes
every once in a blue moon it pulls out a
thought-provoking answer
if you had a billboard here we go
metaphorically speaking to get a message
a quote a question an image anything out
to billions of people
if you prefer a push notification to all
of their phones
what might you choose for that
yeah you you did ask me that last time
and i love this question
and the answer i gave to that before
i remember was light just that one word
and what i meant by it was to choose
light
versus darkness in our life to look for
the light to pursue it wherever we can
and as i think about that question now
with the journey that has gone on over
these last couple of years
i feel like the word would be the same
but with a second meaning so i think
still it would be light but in this
sense now
that the whatever has happened to you in
life whatever hardship whatever pain
they pale in comparison to the power
we have to choose what to do now
in this next moment and in every next
moment
we have a choice to take
the heavier path or the lighter path
and so that's what i mean now when i
think of that word light
there's a lighter way to do life
one of the things that i came across
that i loved in the research
was that now can be measured
that neuro scientists and psychologists
have
assessed in various ways the amount of
time that makes
now now and it's between two to three
seconds
and i mean that has profound
implications to me
the word now comes from nuvis homo
which means a new man or man newly
ennobled
and so if you connect all these themes
together it makes for such a profound
thing that in this moment whatever's
gone before in this moment
we have a choice in that two to three
seconds we have a choice
profound things can happen in two three
seconds we've talked about some of them
you can say
thank you for something you can say i'm
sorry you can say i forgive you
you can say let's start over. you can
say
let's move on or you can just pause for
three seconds
you can just pause breathe
[Laughter]
you can you can breathe for three
seconds
and so in all of these ways
we can use this next moment to find this
other alternative type
of light choosing the light not just
in the sense of tone or
benevolent charge but also
in the sense of of weight
whether that be a physical emotional
psychological
or otherwise that's cool i have never
had a guest
revisit that question use the same
billboard but with an entirely different
yet complimentary meaning that's very
cool
quite enjoy that well we should not
expect any less from greg mcewen
the author of as many of you have
already gathered essentialism
subtitle the disciplined pursuit of les
and his new book effortless
subtitle make it easier to do what
matters most you can find him on twitter
at gregory
mckeown m-c-k-e-o-w-n
on greg mcewen.com and certainly on all
the other social that we'll link to
in the show notes at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast
greg is there anything else that you
would like to
say request of the audience any closing
comments that you would like to add
before we wrap up
i just want to thank you tim for what
you're doing it really does matter in
the world and
it's just all over the place that i hear
from people
that that are really tuned in and really
get a lot of positive from
the work that you do and of course
people see the upsides i'm sure they
they can see oh it's great to have that
kind of impact in the world and so on
but they won't see
the downsides or the sacrifices or the
things that you have given up
for the things that you've gained and i
just wanted to say genuinely
thank you for what you do and for having
me on today
thank you greg for saying that and it's
entirely my pleasure this has been a lot
of fun
i have copious notes in front of me and
i really think that
at the top of the pyramid sort of the
note
that then can cascade down and echo
through all the other notes
is it's all so simple
it can often be so simple and we just
have to take the time to look for it
and that's something that you've done
and i
greatly admire your thinking i enjoy
your writing
and i wish you and yours all the best
and thanks for
taking the time to speak with me today
thank you tim
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hour workweek.com that's
four 4hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
freshbooks when you're running your own
business it's easy to get weighed down
by work that doesn't get you
paid that's why i love freshbooks and
have been recommending
them for years on this podcast it's an
all-in-one accounting and invoicing
solution built for small business owners
like you i've polled tons and tons of my
listeners and readers
who've brought up fresh books over and
over again and you guys have better
things to do so do i
then get caught up in admin work whether
you're a podcaster or creative agency
you can choose a plan that's right for
you
freshbooks has been used by more than 24
million people
and it can save you more than 11 hours a
week by automating invoices
expense tracking online payments and so
much more
easy to understand reports an intuitive
dashboard let you know at a glance where
your business stands you can create
customize and send branded and
professional looking invoices in about
30 seconds
you can also avoid that awkward exchange
with your clients about overdue payments
freshbooks
automates sending late payment email
reminders
and allows you to send a customized
message on your behalf
freshbooks is a simple and intuitive
tool for small business owners
but if you ever need a bit of help
wrapping your head around something they
have
an award-winning toronto-based support
team who are always
happy to help so try freshbooks free for
30 days no credit card
required go to freshbooks.com tim
and enter tim ferriss in the how did you
hear about us section
that's freshbooks.com tim and enter my
name
tim ferriss 2rs2s in the how did you
hear about a section one more time
that is freshbooks.com
this episode is brought to you by
headspace life could be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a
one-and-done
band-aid quick is fine but we need stuff
that is durable and that's where
headspace comes in headspace is your
daily dose of mindfulness in the form of
guided meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
and space is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5-star reviews and more than
60 million downloads so people keep
telling you to try meditation and you're
like when would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation headspace can really help you
feel better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation view need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy
it's put a [ __ ] could be puddi comb i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable
and i did a three minute meditation
something like that it's easy
it's fundamental and it always puts me
in
a better space so i'm going through the
basics even though i've meditated for
years i'm going through the basics
once again and i would suggest to anyone
that they
consider starting there headspace makes
it easy for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice with mindfulness
that works for you on your schedule
anytime anywhere
we all want to feel happier we all want
more peace
and headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com
tim that's headspace.com tim for a free
one month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace this is the best deal
offered right now for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today
you